بعد اغلاق ابواب المدارس والجامعات امام
الفتيات وتعليق عمل النساء في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه تضيق حركه طالبان ايضا
المساحه المتاحه امام النساء حيث امر حاكم
اقليم غور الواقع وسط البلاد مؤخرا مقاتل
الحركه بمنع النساء من الخروج من المنازل
لهن في المدينه من دون محرم وقالت مصادر
في اقليم قارئ لصحيفه افغانيها محليه ان
احمد شا- حاكم طالبان في الاقليم عبر عن
غضبه من تعليق بعض المنظمات الاجنبيه
لاعمالها بسبب القرارات الاخيره ضد النساء
وقال ان المؤسسات الاجنبيه هي غير صادقه
مع شعب افغانستان حيث دانا ما وصفه
باستخدام ذريعه لهجوم الغرب على بلاده هذا
وامر شاهد بعدم السماح للمراه بالتجول في
شوارع المدينه دون محرم من الان فصاعدا
ووجهها بتكثيف الدوريات في المدينه لتوقيف
النساء المخالفات كما نقلت صحيفه محليه عن
سيده بالمدينه تشتك من القيود المتزايده
التي تفرضها حركه طالبان قولها انها علمت
بالقرار من صاحب احد المتاجر التي دعاها
للتسوق سريعا والعوده للمنزل من دون ان
تراها دوريات طالبان الاسواق باتت خاليه
من النساء فجاه بعد قرار منع تجوالهن من
دون محرم وهو ما اعتبرته نشطه افغانيه
انتهاكا لحقوق الانسان ويزيد من القيود
المفروضه عن المراه الافغانيه من دون وجه
حق